[Music]
we have learned that this 76 year old
music legend is gravely ill now over the
years et has spent so many amazing
moments with Aretha including one of our
final sit downs
[Music]
never take the music for granted whether
you have a hit or not well
Aretha has plenty of hits 112 on the
charts along the way
winning 18 Grammy Award the audience's
that come expect to see you do what you
do do your thing this all despite some
serious health problems through the
years eight years ago Aretha was denying
cancer rumors saying she had a tumor
removed in a later statement Franklin
said quote I've lost a lot of weight due
to side effects of medicine how are you
feeling everything is great you're doing
wonderful yes I felt really really good
tonight I could have jumped another hour
that was a retha with Nancy in 2011 she
also sounded upbeat in our 2016
interview with michael jackson's nephew
TJ how are you doing health-wise I'm
doing very well as the old folks say I'm
stepping right along but in her last
public performance November of last year
for the Elton John AIDS Foundation
Aretha looked frail and now a family
friend confirms to ET that the gravely
ill Aretha is surrounded by family and
friends and they're asking the public
for prayers and privacy I like being
given respect and I like to give it
one of the truly amazing voices star
reaction has been pouring in
Mariah tweeted praying for the Queen of
Soul while Missy Elliott said we must
celebrate the living legends while they
are here to see it and that she is
legend always in our hearts